spionagefall bei merkels sprecher
steffen seibert laut verfassungsschutz
hat ein mitarbeiter sei jahrelang für
den ägyptischen geheimdienst spioniert
bei mir ist jetzt bild reporter wie ein
stritzel du bist mit diesem fall
vertraut wie kam der überhaupt ans licht
genau ein etwas ungewöhnlicher fall auch
in der art und weise die veröffentlicht
wurde
wer öffentlich wurde nicht durch den
gestern vorgestellten
verfassungsschutzbericht durch
innenminister seehofer gestern
präsentiert öffnet sich dann auf seite
391 beamte des bundeskriminalamtes ein
exekutiv maßnahmen wie es dort heißt
durchgeführt haben gegen einen
mitarbeiter von merkels von merkels
regierungssprecher seibert
dieser mitarbeiter war anscheinend im
besucherdienst des bundespresseamtes
tätig und soll jahrelang für einen
ägyptischen geheimdienst spioniert haben
kann ein was für informationen konnte
denn dieser mann überhaupt kommen in
dieser position weiß man genaueres also
ich nehme stark an das ist noch unklar
welche informationen er genau geliefert
hat aber ich nehme stark an das ja nur
einen sehr beschränkten wenn überhaupt
zugang hatte zu eingestuften
informationen in dieser position beim
besucherdienst allerdings über einen
zeitraum von mehreren jahren wird er
natürlich auch über den wie man das
kapital sagt flurfunk durchaus
vielleicht sachen aufgeschnappt haben
die für seinen für seinen für den
ägyptischen geheimdienst relevant oder
interessant sein
viel wichtiger ist aber glaube ich dass
er in dieser position als besucherdienst
zugang hat er zu den daten von
ausländischen journalisten die sich auch
beim bundespresseamt akkreditieren
vor allem im ägyptischen journalisten
oppositionellen dissidenten
möglicherweise die in deutschland leben
oder anderswo die möglicherweise auch
unter pseudonym ansonsten publizieren
oder filmaufnahmen und so weiter tätigen
und er bekommt eben über die über die
akkreditierungsstelle im bundespresseamt
man lernen an deren klarnamen an deren
ja sonst wir in kontakt und
wohnmöglichkeiten heran die für das
regime von diktator von kritischen
diktator als die sie durchaus relevant
sein können
wie geht es da jetzt weiter was gab es
für konsequenzen und welche konsequenzen
gibt es macht also zunächst einmal
ermittelt die bundesanwaltschaft gegen
den mann wegen geheimdienstlicher
agententätigkeit wann welche
konsequenzen das dann auch
kritischer ebene hatte ich nehme an da
werden die ermittlungen abgewartet
das ungewöhnliche an dem fall ist man
muss man muss sagen dass auch andere
dass auch andere regime in deutschland
spionieren dass auch andere diktatoren
in deutschland ihre geheimdienst er
spielen lassen und vor allem ihre
landsleute ausspionieren lassen das
ungewöhnlich in dem fall ist aber dass
man jemanden rekrutiert hat der im
umfeld der bundesregierung arbeitet das
heißt eigentlich die politische
konsequenz müsste eigentlich sein da
müsste ein ägypter gehen also der
ägyptische präsident möglicherweise oder
dass jemand ausgewiesen wird
wir werden den menschen die im umfeld
der bundeskanzlerin arbeiten überhaupt
überprüft
da gibt's natürlich
sicherheitsüberprüfungen also gibt es
verschiedene stufen die spd 13 also auf
der höchsten stufe auf der sd teil
werden auch also nicht immer abfrage von
datenbanken ob irgendwas vorlegt gegen
denjenigen sondern wird natürlich vor
allem geschaut hat derjenige schulden
hat derjenige anderer gibt es andere
möglichkeiten die man in der presse zu
machen oder ist ja irgendwelchen anderen
ebenen anfällig auf der höchsten auf der
s3 werden auch gespräche mit personen
aus dem unmittelbaren umfeld der person
aus dem umfeld der person getätigt aber
in so einer position war jetzt dieser
mann offenbar nicht dass er so ins
detail überprüft werde schließe er
schließlich das richtig ich glaube
selbst wenn er nach einer spd überprüft
worden wäre kann ich kann tatsächlich
nicht sagen wie genau die die
anforderung für den sucher dienst sind
selbst dann ist es natürlich nicht
auszuschließen dass er irgendwann
rekrutiert wurde durch eine ägyptische
geheimdienst die vorgehensweise modus
operandi die dienste da an den tag
länger sind der regel dass man die leute
wenn sie ein visum brauchen für ägypten
wenn sie ja zum beispiel die botschaft
aufsuchen der mann soll einen
migrationshintergrund haben also
naheliegenderweise wahrscheinlich in
ägyptischen migrationshintergrund dass
die dann rekrutiert werden bei oder dass
gespräche angebahnt werden wenn sie sich
ja in der botschaft befinden und das
daneben ja dass darüber sozusagen die
leute rekrutiert werden